all right meanwhile is former ukip
leader it's time for him to join us now
he's one of the loudest voices for
brexit you know him fox news contributor
nigel farage
nigel very predictable to think that
everyone is going to excel and say i'm
so glad
the interrupter in chief is no longer
president anything surprising
so far no not really i mean look the
rest are globalists
donald trump believes in the nation
state so to them a great relief
that he wasn't there uh that america
sent a
slightly uh president who wasn't going
to challenge anything because he
probably didn't understand too much of
what was genuinely going on around him
but you know they love i mean this g7
was all about consensus everybody
agreeing on everything
take for example why they like jay biden
on global warming
everyone says we're all gonna die
tomorrow we must cut carbon emissions
and give a hundred billion dollars to
third world countries
to help them reduce carbon emissions
applause all round
open the champagne right if trump had
been there
he would have said hang on guys why are
we doing all of this
when china is opening two new
coal-fired power stations every single
week
but of course joe biden wasn't going to
say that donald trump would have said
that
that explains to you why they think it's
wonderful that trump has gone
and biden is there so i want to ask you
a question what happened to boris
johnson i still can't get my head around
these comments when he asked about a
post-pandemic world let's listen
we're building back better together and
building that greener and building that
fairer and
building back more equal and
uh more in a more gender neutral and
perhaps like a more feminine way is he
gender neutral or feminine i i don't
like either choice
it was an obvious contradiction there
wasn't there but i mean the whole tone
of it
it was metropolitan liberal elite
virtually becoming the green party now
whether this is his new wife
who was an eco warrior that's had this
influence i don't know what i do know is
this is not what conservative voters
gave him
a big majority for and he just seems to
be so
easily influenced by all of the others i
have to say
it really was that little speech was
astonishing
um and told us that boris boris is not
really a conservative
and i know that many americans saw him
perhaps as being a mini trump
uh g7 has confirmed he is not
you know what's interesting is that does
he not remember that he would probably
not have that job
if barack obama and if joe biden was the
next president not donald trump it was
donald trump that was support of brexit
it was barack obama and vice president
biden who said do not leave the eu you
go to the back of the queue
now he's president does he remember this
well i think the thing about boris is
you know boris joined the brexit
campaign at five minutes to midnight
it was people like me that put the hard
work in over many many years
and now okay brexit is done and that's
good but when you hear boris on
china in particular you know and he's
saying tonight
very clearly he does not want a new cold
war with china he wants us to go
soft on china you realize that for boris
brexit was a political expediency not
something he really believed
in whereas donald trump absolutely
believed in brexit and still does
so i'm afraid that boris is quite a big
disappointment for many people and
that's the problem with multilateralism
if germany
france and britain don't want to get
tough with china
that's going to put the world in
jeopardy and america can't go along with
that if we care about our future and
once again we're going to ask to lead
that's the problem he wants to be one of
the guys and we need a leader
yeah absolutely and trump was good on
china i can even see the influence of
what trump said on china on biden
who is trying to sound tough without
really meaning it
sadly most of the european leaders are
happy
to sell their souls to the chinese
communist party
and they're never going to fear joe
biden on this truck i believe that
donald trump
is the only man who can coalesce the
west
around a policy that actually stands up
and challenges
the chinese communist party nobody else
in global affairs
can do it and you can like donald trump
you can dislike donald trump
but he was absolutely right on the china
issue
and that's why at some point before too
long not just america
but we in the western world need him his
courage
and his vision back in the white house
thanks so much nigel appreciate it he
knows you well and you know him well so
you're not just speaking off the cuff
appreciate it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else